Advances in genealogical DNA testing have raised existential questions for many,...
...but not much compares to the experience of Albert Perry,...
...whose genetic material offers new clues about the origin of the human species.
An African-American man from South Carolina,...
...Perry let a relative send in his DNA for analysis.
But when the testing company tried to track his Y chromosome, they simply couldn't.
Further research reveal that Perry's Y chromosome...
...came from a lineage that broke off from other species about 338,000 years ago.
That's long before the first Homo Sapiens or modern humans evolved some 195,000 years ago,...
...making our Y chromosome lineage much longer than geneticists believed.
Researchers eventually linked Perry's DNA to other men in a village in Cameroon,...
...leading them to speculate that modern humans...
...and a since extinct species interbred in Central Africa hundreds of thousands of years ago.